legal expert Glenn kirschner says that
failed former president Donald Trump is
potentially facing 25 years in prison
based on the potential criminal
referrals that he is up against we are
going to listen to him explain it
himself there's a good news week write
up about it Trump May face 25 years in
prison and be blocked from future office
let's listen this is Glenn kirschner on
the Joy Reed program on MSNBC uh
remember nobody here is saying Trump is
going to prison we're talking about
based on the crimes Trump may be charged
with what would the potential sentence
be a referral doesn't mean they're
Prosecuting they don't have the power to
do that but would such a referral at
least have sort of value even if they
can't get get it all the way to closure
it will have value you know the
Department of Justice Prides itself on
exercising independent prosecutorial
discretion but they can't turn a blind
eye to a co-equal branch of government
that has done such an exhaustive
investigation when they pass all of that
evidence over to doj and they recommend
criminal investigations and prosecutions
and here's the thing it's great that
they're talking about obstructing
official proceedings that's a 20-year
offense it's great that they're talking
about conspiracy to commit offenses
against the United States that's a
five-year offense but the important one
Joy is the one you mentioned
Insurrection why because the available
sentence if you're convicted of
insurrection unlike those other charges
is that you shall be prohibited from
holding office under the United States
that quite frankly is the one I'm
rooting for and of course it continues
to be
stunning that not only can Trump run for
president he he is running for president
even though the campaign so far has been
a complete and total flop now let's be
very real about what I know many of you
consider to be the most important
question here
do presidents get indicted in the United
States could a president get indicted
why has a president never been indicted
in the United States let's start the
conversation with a reminder that no
president has ever done the things
Donald Trump did put that aside for now
because we want to talk now about
historical precedent to put it in one
word
tradition is the reason that presidents
have not historically been indicted by
the Department of Justice and what I
mean by that is
historically out of the principle of
executive immunity which holds the
president is not subject to criminal
prosecution while serving in office
the doj has not pursued charges against
a precedent and the principle behind
that is if you charge a sitting
president
you inhibit their ability to do the job
of being president of the United States
and if a president worries that what
they do might get them indicted while
they are President they might act other
than how they believe is in the best
interest of the country for fear of a
personal prosecution or because of the
distraction of a criminal trial however
after leaving office there is nothing
that would prevent or preclude a
president from being investigated from
being potentially charged with crimes
and from being prosecuted importantly
you also have impeachment impeachment
for high crimes and misdemeanors is a
completely separate process from
Criminal prosecution and doesn't require
any crime to have been committed
important to understand that the January
6 committee investigation and potential
criminal referrals would not be for
impeachable offenses because the house
could handle that itself Trump's out of
office he's already been impeached twice
this is about in their investigative
carrying out of their investigative role
the house may come across what are
apparent crimes and refer those to the
Department of Justice tradition is the
only reason
why historically you have not seen
prosecution of a president Trump is now
out of office we may know within hours
whether the house committee says trumps
on the list of people who committed
crimes here's a criminal referral we may
know within hours or a day or two and
then the question will be what does the
doj do under Merit Garland Merit Garland
has said things like Trump running for
president wouldn't get him out of jail
it's not a get out of jail free card
fine but he has not expressed that his
doj actually has the testicular
fortitude for lack of a better term to
really charge Trump so we will see and
we will find out very very soon
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part go shop plant-based bags to replace
single-use Plastics all over your home
you'll save 20 20 percent when you go to
holdon bags.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below